[Music]
while being here in indianapolis for
these last three weeks
has me reminiscing on 30 years ago
when we beat undefeated unlv
defending national champion one of the
greatest
upsets of all time and now i get a
chance
to visit with coach k who's back in
durham north carolina
to relive the magical moments that took
place
during that year
hey holy mackerel how is this happening
it's incredible i guess you have to be
an icon or goat to have a hologram so
this is this is incredible i love it
every time i come here i think about
that 91 championship that we experienced
do you ever look back and just think
about that season
yeah and you know grant to finally get
our first national championship
and and after losing by 30 points in the
national championship game in 90
you know indianapolis will always be a
very very special place for me
there it mike is smile
he knows he has that monkey off his back
you
lost three senior starters from that
team that made it to the finals
but that first day we're in the locker
room and you wrote on the board 1991
national champions well i actually got
chills thinking of that moment because
i thought it was a moment that set the
stage for
the national championship months later
you played with two guys who were
fearless
and christian and bobby you know they're
two of the all-time
competitors and great players in the
history of college basketball and then
to add you
with them we had a trinity there that
could rival anybody in college
basketball unlv
is on some kind of a role they are quite
simply an awesome group of athletes
[Music]
just talk about how stacked that unlv
team was
and how no one expected us to win well
yes somebody expected us to win we did i
genuinely remember when we got on that
plane to fly to indianapolis
that we were going to beat them how did
you go about
preparing us for that great unlv ball
club
we kept reinforcing that if we could get
them
in the last couple minutes in a close
game
we would have the advantage because they
had pretty much annihilated everybody
everyone wonders how duke will handle
this game psychologically after that
contest a year ago
i can still remember you guys going on
the court
you guys were stone cold killers and you
guys
believed you believed augment has it
taken away
he finishes leitner called for it he got
it beautiful feed
mike shuszewski he has his guys
believing they can play this unlv
team i think from the start we let them
know that
this wasn't last year and uh there was a
moment in the second half
that it felt like they had maybe a
five-point lead
and we're kind of pulling away a little
bit and bobby
raised up still plenty of time
maybe the biggest shot that a player hit
during my time here at duke was bobby's
three what a big three by bobby
and you could see in their face it was
like in a
big time fight we landed a huge punch
[Applause]
and now we were in that the crucible of
two minutes
that we had talked about that pressure
can duke pull off one of the biggest
upsets in the final four
angles has done it
duke has upset unlv
everyone's going crazy in the hoosier
dome there's a celebration and you're
you're trying to keep us all
like composed like there's one more game
we just won
as big a game as duke has ever won
now we were going to be tested in it and
you guys
really passed the
[Applause]
has test its first national championship
obviously we win the game against kansas
what was that like
you know you don't think about legacy or
anything like that
it was more we did it we did it now
you know my thing can we ever do it
again and
we kept that team together and won it
again the following year
all right coach well hey i appreciate
this it was our first national
championship
in my first hologram so
good stuff coach well thank you so much
i appreciate you thank you
that was awesome
you